>> Talia Guzman Gonzalez:
OK, buenas tardes.
Welcome everyone.
I'm going to do an introduction
in Spanish, but I wanted
to welcome everyone to
the Hispanic Division
of the Library of Congress.
As you all know, this week
we'll begin the celebration
of National Hispanic
Heritage month,
and we have a wonderful lineup
of nine events for this week.
The program is in the front,
so you're welcome to see it.
We've been working
hard and we hope
to see you in all of the events.
Bueno, bienvenidos y bienvenidas
a la Sala Hispánica de lectura
de la Biblioteca del Congreso,
donde nos reunimos hoy para
dar inicio a los eventos de
conmemoración de la herencia --
del mes de la herencia hispana.
Este evento es organizado por la
División Hispana y la Hispanic
Cultural Society de la
Biblioteca del Congreso.
Nuestra asociación es una
asociación de empleados
hispanos y no hispanos,
pero también amantes
de la cultura hispana.
La misión de la Hispanic
Cultural Society es preservar,
promover y compartir todos los
aspectos de la cultura hispana
entre los empleados
de la biblioteca,
a través de eventos
como charlas,
conciertos y lecturas
de poesía,
como la que tenemos hoy.
Es un honor para mí darle
la bienvenida al escritor
ecuatoriano Raúl Vallejo.
Raúl es natural de
Manta en Ecuador.
Recibió su licenciatura
en letras en la Universidad
Católica de Guayaquil
y luego un Masters
of Arts en la Universidad de
Maryland en College Park y con
una beca Fullbright LASPAU.
Su doctorado es de la
universidad Pablo de Olavide
en Sevilla.
Raúl Vallejo ha
publicado, entre otros,
los siguientes libros
de cuentos.
"Máscaras para un
concierto", en 1986,
"Sólo de palabras" de 1988,
"Fiesta de solitarios" de 1992,
que ganó el premio 70 años de
Diario del Universo y el premio
Joaquín Gallegos Lara,
al mejor libro del año.
También ha ganado
premios por su libro
"Huellas de amor eterno" en 2000
y "Pubis equinoccial" en 2013.
Ha publicado las
novelas "Acoso textual",
que también ganó el premio
Joaquín Gallegos Lara a la
mejor novela en 1999 y el
premio nacional del libro en el
año 2000.
Otras novelas incluyen
"El alma en los labios",
"Marilyn en el Caribe",
que ganó el premio en 2015
de la novela corta de la
Universidad Javeriana
de Colombia,
y "El perpetuo exiliado",
el premio internacional de
novela Héctor Rojas Erazo.
En 2018, con el libro "Gabriela,
parábola de transeúntes",
aun inédita, ganó el premio
nacional de novela corta Miguel
Donoso Pareja.
Tenemos aquí en la
biblioteca, todos esos libros,
incluyendo sus poemarios
"Cánticos para Oriana",
"Crónicas del mestizo"
y "Missa solemnis".
Además de literatura tiene
varios libros de ensayos
literarios publicados.
También ha recibido el premio
Sexto Continente del Relato
Erótico en España y el de
poesía José María Valverde.
Es el fundador y director
de "Pie de página,
revista literaria de
creación y crítica".
Ha servido a su país como
ministro de educación,
embajador en Colombia
y ministro de cultura.
Actualmente es miembro de
la comisión gestora de la
Universidad de las
Artes de Guayaquil,
vicerrector de investigación y
postgrado y dirige la escuela de
literatura y es docente
de la misma.
Hoy nos va a hablar de su libro
"Mística del tabernario",
que ya recibió un premio
internacional de poesía,
José Lezama Lima, en 2017,
y el cual tenemos aquí si
alguien quiere adquirirlo,
también lo tenemos a la venta.
Y bueno, por favor acompáñenme
darle la bienvenida a
Raúl Vallejo.
[ Aplausos ]
[ Conversación ininteligible ]
>> Raul Vallejo: Bueno,
muy buenas tardes a todas
las personas aquí presentes.
Para mí es realmente un honor
y es satisfactorio estar aquí
celebrando el mes
de la hispanidad,
aquí justamente en el
salón de lectura hispánico.
Es una maravilla entrar
acá, estar rodeado de --
bueno, de todos los
que están aquí,
con estos nombres
como Cervantes.
Y me enorgullece ver el nombre
de Montalvo y Rodó, Montalvo,
Juan Montalvo, es un intelectual
ecuatoriano del siglo XIX,
es un intelectual paradigmático
del siglo XIX ecuatoriano,
y para nosotros es uno de los
pensadores más ilustres del
romanticismo de Hispanoamérica.
Gracias por la invitación,
y tenemos un --
hoy día voy a leer textos de
este libro mío que se llama
"Mística del tabernario".
"Mística del tabernario"
es un libro que yo escribí
íntegramente en Colombia --
íntegramente en Colombia
mientras viví por cinco años y
más ahí, estaba como embajador
de mi país en Colombia.
Y siempre me preguntan
por cómo,
teniendo una función
así, sigues escribiendo.
Yo ahí escribí
también mi novela
"El perpetuo exiliado" que
está aquí exhibida entonces,
¿en qué momento escribes?
Y yo les digo, "bueno, yo
puedo escribir porque no
veo televisión".
Entonces, y eso -- desde hace
mucho tiempo no veo televisión,
realmente.
Hoy día el concepto de
televisión ha evolucionado a
Netflix, y entonces uno puede
ver las cosas a su gusto,
a su tiempo y sin publicidad,
lo cual es una maravilla.
En todo caso, quiero empezar
este recital con un texto que es
una suerte de autorretrato.
Así como los pintores hacen
autorretratos, los poetas,
los autores también
hacemos autorretratos.
En este caso, este
autorretrato desde el año 2003.
Éste no está en el libro
"Mística del tabernario",
pero siempre un autorretrato
es una suerte de carta
de presentación.
"He sido en otras vidas parte
de la transparencia condenada.
Mancebo y aprendiz en
academia de filósofo griego.
Prostituta azotada en las
cercanías de un templo repleto
de mercaderes, predicador
escondido en catacumbas o
expuesto en la arena
de un coliseo.
Bruja servida para saciar los
escrúpulos de Torquemada.
Adorador de huacas en
tiempos del virrey Toledo.
Negra en Alabama, judío en
Auschwitz, poeta en Wall Street.
He sido lo que está el
margen del camino y que el
viajante escupe.
La basura que arrojan los
decentes sin que nadie los vea.
El mal pensamiento de la
anciana que no sabe bien por
qué suspira.
La desenfrenada mano
solitaria del quinceañero.
El espejo en donde mira el
nacimiento de sus formas la
núbil desconcertada.
Las cartas de aquellos amantes
que transgredían el espacio con
papeles perfumados.
Soga de ahorcado, bola
de cristal enmudecida,
piedra de sacrificio mayo.
He sido aquello que el orden
y el poder marcaron con fuego.
Remero de galeón sacudido
por el latigazo continuo en
las espaldas.
Enano y hazmerreír en
castillos medievales.
Críticos del mecenazgo en
la Florencia renacentista.
Monja de clausura ávida de
mundo y con vocación para
las ciencias.
Curaca sublevado y
seguidor de Tupac Amaru.
Palafrenero de palacio,
concubina fea,
madrastra en cuentos de hadas.
He sido lo que se
habla en voz baja,
lo que está prohibido
para menores,
lo que se acepta bajo la mesa,
lo que se compra a hurtadillas.
Muchacha adolescente de
espectáculo nudista en Bangkok.
Jinetera comunista en las noches
del malecón de La Habana.
Acompañante de ejecutivos de
una agencia de Dupont Circle.
Mulatillo que deambulas las
madrugadas por las playas
de Río.
VIH positivo, aprendiz
de masajista.
Amante del alcalde
en pueblo chico.
Soy el mundo lapidado por los
que arrojaron con rabia las
primeras piedras".
En el caso de "Mística
del tabernario",
este es un libro que --
Este es un libro que se
compone de algunas partes,
y una primera parte tiene
que ver con un conversatorio
escénico llamado -- yo lo
he llamado un conversatorio
escénico de la postmodernidad.
Chapinero bajo es un
barrio de Bogotá,
se dice que es el
barrio del arcoíris.
Es un barrio con fuerte
presencia de la comunidad LGBTI,
pero además es un
barrio bohemio,
y la idea de estos textos es
que se trata de una reunión de
poetas que están
en una taberna,
hablando de infinidad de cosas.
Yo he seleccionado algunos
textos de los poetas.
Son algunas voces.
Es la voz de un poeta indignado,
es la voz de un cronista
postcolonial,
es la voz de un poeta
manteño, huancavilca,
es la voz de un homus
libidinosus, etcétera.
Son algunas voces las que están
en diálogo y esa es la idea de
este poemario.
Esta es la voz del
poeta indignado.
"Los poetas del siglo
pasado están muertos,
y los poetas del siglo
presente carecen de vida.
¡Ah, los intelectuales
de hoy!,
narcisos que se miran el ombligo
como espejo que les devuelve el
rostro de la nada.
Cayó el muro de
Berlín, aleluya.
Los poetas, cronistas del
nuevo tiempo ya no pregonan la
democracia de Whitman, pero
se cantan a sí mismos como si
fueran un girasol
en el desierto.
Hipócritas lectores
del mundo, uníos.
Los poetas son ciegos, ante
los nuevos muros del imperio se
arrodillan y los adoran.
La poesía es un arma cargada
-- descargada de mundo.
Poetas suicidas solo
miran para dentro de sí.
La vida se reduce a la letra --
inútil, la única calle que
transitamos nos conduce a un
final muerto.
Hipócritas transeúntes
del distrito, uníos.
Los poetas son las anillos que
se embriagan en este barrio
habitado por los
seres del arcoíris."
Es un diálogo entre
el vate memorioso y el
criticón literario.
"La poesía sirve para
la conquista amorosa.
Ese es un concepto
libidinoso del arte.
La poesía hace la
revolución social.
Infantilismo izquierdista
de la palabra.
La poesía no sirve para nada,
nihilismo a base de cannabis.
La poesía nos habla
de nuestra finitud.
La muerte no dialoga
con el hedonismo".
Este texto lo dice
el antipoetucho,
y lo dice un poco como un
ritmo -- con un ritmo urbano.
"En tu ciudad también
existe una calle 13.
Hay que estar pensando que uno
puede ir marcando el ritmo como
como un tacho de basura, ¿no?
Entonces, somos los olvidados
de mundos escondidos en las
vitrinas de los centros
comerciales.
Somos desahuciados, somos los
perdidos para este planeta de
las transnacionales.
Pero en la compra y
venta de la libertad,
sobrevivimos en la
calle 13 de tu ciudad.
Somos los modelos de fotos de
"Crónica roja" y para UNICEF,
estadísticas de la pobreza.
Somos los desechables para que
nos recoja de los estercoleros,
la patrulla de limpieza.
Pero tras la hipocresía
de templos sin edad,
sobrevivimos en la
calle 13 de tu ciudad".
Somos clientes de la
tienda estatal de marihuana,
y aprendimos a usar
nuestros puños y cuchillos.
Somos los votantes de la
democracia del mañana,
y reciclamos esperanza
ante los próximos pillos.
Pero tras el crimen en
los medios de la verdad,
sobrevivimos en la
calle 13 de tu ciudad.
Somos el asombro de
estilistas y las buenas gentes,
marcamos territorio por
la fuerza del corazón,
somos los del barrio, los
del parque, los indigentes,
peligro para la capital
de los zombis y la razón.
Pero tras el paso bacano
y la puta realidad,
sobrevivimos en la
calle 13 de tu ciudad".
No soy tan rapero como parece.
Este texto es un texto de --
Que tiene que ver
con lo siguiente:
En Cartagena de Indias se dio
una Cumbre de las Américas.
Unos agentes del servicio
secreto de los Estados Unidos,
que iban en adelantada,
ellos contrataron a una
prostituta y luego no le
quisieron pagar, entonces,
se armó un escándalo.
Es una pena porque
la cumbre finalmente,
en términos mediáticos,
quedó reducida al episodio del
agente de seguridad de Obama que
deja adelantada, contrato a
una prostituta cartagenera,
no le quiso pagar y entonces,
yo he hecho este primer soneto
alejandrino para la meretriz
de Cartagena.
Veamos. "La prensa es libre
para averiguarlo todo,
Dania Londoño Suárez,
26 años.
Madre soltera de un niño de 7,
de padres caleño y
meretriz de Cartagena.
El Daily News de Nueva York
sentencia que tú eres la causa
de los daños, después de todo,
el hombre que te contrató es
un pecador en tierra ajena".
Ah, la carne es débil,
y tú, Dania,
eres la antigua tentación
de los olvidos.
El espectador de Bogotá nos
regala la primicia de tus fotos
y te nomina 'la mujer que tienen
aprietos al servicio secreto de
los Estados Unidos'.
Playboy te busca para ofrecer en
este verano tu piel de Mata Hari
latina, y SoHo, que
a todas las empelota,
dedicó tu carne de
$500 a sus lectores.
Oh, la heroica está herida
y fotos del banquete de
presidentes ya no vi.
Las calles de Cartagena
ofrecen dulces y ron.
El amor no es cosa de doctores.
Él declara, como
en el Génesis,
'por culpa de la hija de
la serpiente me perdí'.
Adán fue el primero en acusarte
cuando reconoció ante Yahvé
sus horrores.
'La mujer que me diste por
compañera me dio el fruto del
árbol, y yo comí'".
Poeta indignado.
"¡Ah, poetas comprometidos
solo con la poesía!
Aunque la poesía está
comprometida con la vida.
Yo sólo quiero una playa para
mis pies y un horizonte para
mi mirada.
Quiero una alameda
para mis hermanos,
árboles que cobijen el paso
de miles de cuerpos bellos,
envueltos en banderas multicolor
y abrazos de todos los sexos.
Quiero el agua de la paz para
los sedientos de verdad y
justicia, y la tierra para
las manos desplazadas que se
hundieron en ellas.
Quiero las flores y las brisas
frescas para aliviar las heridas
y el cielo luminoso para
los días del beso y
la reconciliación.
Yo soy aquel que ayer nomás
decía, 'viva la revolución'.
Yo soy aquel que
hoy no más digo,
'viva la libertad de empresa'.
Ah, poetas de espaldas al mundo,
fantasmas de espejos que les
devuelven la condena de una
sonrisa de gatos sin cabeza".
Este es un texto -- que habla
de los feminicidios en el mundo.
Lo dice el cronista poscolonial
en esta conversación.
"Marisela Escobedo,
mexicana de 52 años.
Le dimos un balazo por reclamar
en Ciudad Juárez el asesinato
de su hija y más de 3.000
mujeres solo en 2010.
Sakineh Mohammid Ashtianiati
[fonético], iraní de 43 años,
condenada a muerte
por adúltera.
Ya le propinamos 99 azotes,
ahora la ejecutaremos en
la horca o lapidándola.
Gina Potes, Colombiana
de 35 años.
Lleva 24 cirugías
reconstructivas en 15 años.
Le desfiguramos el
rostro con ácido,
igual que a 55 mujeres en
2010 como cadena perpetua.
Amina ben Abdellahalinas
[fonético], saudí,
la decapitamos en
Jaf [fonético] por
practicar brujería.
Que agradezca que ya no quemamos
vivas a las brujas como en
tiempos de la Inquisición.
A María Teherán y
su hija, ecuatorianas,
brujas de que Calhuací,
escarmentamos tam [fonético].
Justicia indígena azotó con
ortiga y bañó con agua helada
en plaza pública tam.
Me avergüenza ser hombre
en un mundo feminicida".
Al final es la voz del
poeta manteño, huancavilca,
que se despide de
este conversatorio.
"Que emitan la factura con
cargo a mis derechos de autor.
Con tres Guiness al hilo en
el Molly Bloom de Tel Aviv,
reclamé en la barra una
camiseta con la imagen de
James Joyce.
Con tres chapinero porter al
hilo en esta taberna soy el
corazón perforado de
José Asunción Silva,
el laberinto samario de
José Luís Díaz Granados.
Le digo adiós a María León
Arias Cano, la actriz invitada,
y me voy con la fragancia
colorida del jardín de
Celestino Mutis, y camino en
solitud por la avenida Caracas
con mi ángel guardián
embolatado,
y la promesa del ajiaco
para el aguayabo de mañana.
Así me esfumaré en la penumbra
del parque del virrey como si
fuera el poeta Jota
Mario en paños menores,
y seré el quejido del agua
del canal y el runrún del
follaje escandaloso.
Digo adiós con la piadosa
vergüenza de ocuparme de estos
versos y de compartir con
ustedes mi orfandad redimida por
la poesía.
Es la hora distrital para
cerrar esta taberna".
Esta otra parte del
texto se llama
"procreación de identidades".
Y tiene unos textos más bien --
si estos eran unos textos más
de carácter expresionista,
más objetivos, estos textos
son todo lo contrario.
Son unos textos de carácter
un poco más íntimo,
mucho más personales.
Ya ustedes los van a ver.
"Ante tus ojos de guepardo.
¿Cuántos hombres he sido
antes de ser el que te sonríe?
El que mira tus ojos de guepardo
con sus pupilas dilatadas.
Si descubrieras la ajíva
que esconde mi traje,
carnosidad secreta que
acumula tanto fuego encendido,
tanta leña convertida
en brasa inextinguible.
¿Cuál de aquellos hombres
preferiría que fuera hoy día?
Estoy hecho de retazos,
de parches e hilachas.
Llevo el olvido adherido
a mis huesos,
llevo la memoria
diluida en mi sangre.
Resucitado por la rugiente
mirada que me descubre,
sobreviviente de lo cotidiano
sin heroísmo posible,
llevo arena de la playa de mi
pueblo en mis torpes zapatos
cargados de mundo.
Tú lo sabes, mientras
acaricias mi mejilla.
Si sólo fuera memoria,
existiría como espectro
en volandas.
Si, en cambio, sólo fuera
olvido, sería sombra,
que se desvanece como
viento de verano,
más soy memoria y olvido
y esta sonrisa mía bebe la
prolongación de vida que la
pupila marihuana de tus ojos de
guepardo le regalan".
"¿Te acuerdas de Ingapirca?
¿Te acuerdas en Ingapirca?
Muro de piedra antigua que
se eleva delante de mí,
las junturas pegadas
con dureza de vida.
Entre ellas crece la hiedra,
milenaria vegetación
de lo perenne.
Contra las piedras me
estrello, diminuto, ignorante,
cegado de luz me
desangró y porfío.
Soy transeúnte extraviado en
las ruinas de la persistencia,
toco con mis labios secos la
humedad de tus puertas abiertas,
y me enceguece la dolorosa
y exultante maravilla del
día pleno.
Todo es rumor de viento que
envuelve la ruina de los que
alguna vez se amaron".
"Él, ella".
"Ella era él en un cuerpo
que no le pertenecía.
Después, él fue ella en un
cuerpo libre de etiquetas.
Ahora es ella y es él,
y su encanto es la corriente
de un río que fluye,
que brama y arrasa escrúpulos.
Él, ella, procreación
de identidades,
su ser es un estuario en el
que desembocan las almas que se
liberan de las vergüenzas
de sus tumbas."
"Trashumancia consumada.
Yo no sé cómo cantarle
a ella, ¿en qué tono?
¿Con cuántas notas?
No sé cómo cantar afinado
si su mirada me enmudece y su
sonrisa me ciega.
Yo no sé cómo contarle
a él que ya no es pero
todavía existe.
¿En qué nota?
¿Con cuántos tonos?
No sé cómo decírselo,
si su sonrisa me enciende.
¿Cómo contarle a él,
transfigurado en ella,
si ella transita
con él a cuestas?
Soy una nota desafinada
en tono menor,
ella es un ser de
piel sin bemoles.
Trashumancia consumada
en un nuevo cuerpo".
"Mariposa.
Mira esa mariposa que vuela
libre y admiras en sus colores,
en su plasticidad,
en su transparencia.
Ayer fue oruga que
reptaba por la tierra.
Mañana, crucificada
con alfileres,
será adorno de coleccionistas
o polvillo del camino que jamás
se detiene".
Imitación, imposible,
de Borges.
"La luna que te mira no es la
luna de Borges en Buenos Aires.
Tu mirada la ha hecho otra,
luna que me mira con la
caricia de tus ojos".
Niña de porcelana.
Fue deslumbramiento a la
vuelta de una esquina.
Una niña de porcelana me
mostró su vida por delante,
y en esa sonrisa vivaz que
parecía emerger de sus ojos,
descubrí que el cuerpo que
alberga mi alma andariega,
se sintió prisionero, por un
instante, de tanta inocencia."
Villa de Leyva es una ciudad,
un municipio que queda
cerca de Bogotá.
Es un municipio que mantiene
todavía su carácter colonial.
En algún momento fue una
ciudad importante de paso.
Hoy día es una ciudad
que tiene --
se ha mantenido con más o
menos 12.000, 13.000 habitantes.
Entonces, sigue teniendo
ese espíritu,
es un pueblo muy lindo.
En la sierra, no?
Perdida en Villa de Leyva.
"El frío de la tarde
resbala por la montaña,
y el sol andino besa
la tierra reseca.
El viento desolado
muerde mi rastro,
y las piedras de la plaza
ahogan mis huellas vanas.
En esta villa, detenida
en un tiempo colonial,
¿cómo la memoria resulta
presencia dócil de tu alma
indómita y mi yo andante?
Vida, te pierdo en esta
tristeza de frío".
Rastro del solo.
"Y en lo profundo de nuestro
abismo nos vemos azorados,
como en un impecable
espejo de agua.
No es Narciso quien nos devuelve
el rostro, sino la soledad".
Dos tazas de café
sobre una mesa.
"Un café siempre es un
pretexto para otro café.
Entre uno y otro
la vida despierta,
en las palabras medidas
para cada taza.
En la borra del café primero
leo enterrados tantos lechos en
los que soy olvido, despertares
con el alma cercenada,
cuerpos felices,
yertos en la memoria.
Las tasas vacías sobre la
mesa albergan tanto costado
desgarrado en cada derrota,
confesiones paridas en
primaveras dolientes.
Las tazas del segundo café
aguardan nuestras palabras
ancladas en el fondo de
esa turbulencia secreta que
nos asfixia.
Emergerán sabias,
añejadas en tanta renuncia,
dispuestas a la vida
de otro café.
Muy bien. Esta parte del
poemario se refiere a las
redes sociales.
Y esto es como imaginarse de
qué manera ha cambiado el
paisaje urbano, ¿no?
Una vez estaba yo en la en
la avenida 72 y séptima en
Bogotá, y de repente veo que
todo el mundo andaba con una
mano en la oreja.
Entonces, andaba con la mano en
la oreja y todo el mundo subía
y bajaba por la avenida
Chile, que es la 72,
con una mano en oreja.
Y todo el mundo yo hablando,
aparente en un soliloquio
shakesperianos, ¿no?
Preguntándose no sé
qué cosas, pero bueno.
Entonces, este poema
responde a ese paisaje urbano.
Paisaje urbano número uno.
"Camina con la mano
sobre su oreja,
sin pausa camina con la mano
sosteniendo la oreja escondida.
Una caracola que atiende
secretos, urgencias,
amores, negocios, tonterías.
No ve a la gente que también
camina con la mano sobre la
oreja, que no mira a toda la
gente incansable para sostener
un grillete de presidiario
mordiendo la oreja.
El paisaje de caminantes
ha cambiado.
La ciudad es una multitud de
orejas ocultas por una mano que
empuja hacia ellas, el grillete
que habla, que oye, palpita".
"Una lengua que lame
hasta el tímpano,
se extravía entre las manos
fundidas a las cabezas de tantos
caminantes solos.
Aún cree que es una persona
que camina con una mano sobre la
oreja perdida.
La ciudad está llena
de grilletes agarrados,
con dientes seductores
de orejas ciegas".
Esta --
Este texto tiene que ver
con los populares "selfies".
Selfie. "El rostro se
apropia de sí mismo,
y es rastro impregnado.
Espejo del ojo que contempla
al que se ve, ojo que mira.
Sonrisas del otro que es el yo
que lo captura desde la mirilla,
incrustada.
Vigía que atalaya a
través de infinitos espejos.
Fotografía de uno mismo
destinada a redes virtuales.
Urgencia inútil de sabernos
etiquetados en muros ajenos".
Hoy debería ser soliloquio 280,
pero para el momento
en que fue escrito,
eran solamente 140 caracteres.
Soliloquio 140.
"140 caracteres para hablar
del amor, de la muerte nuestra,
del mundo, la madrugada que nos
ilumina de los rencores que nos
consumen, un dios.
140 espacios para ocuparlos
con la vida hecha de palabras
comprimidas, de furia
concentrada,
de malabares fatuos que
nos enmascaran de astucia.
140 vacíos para llenar nuestra
soledad de signos viajeros a
través de la nada,
nos envuelven con la misma
tristeza huérfana del
primer hombre."
Que faltaba.
El libro de caras.
"Un libro de caras que
es invención del deseo,
álbum de fotos donde
palpita la perpetua vanidad,
espacio del desencuentro
de un millón de amigos,
cartelera de desventuras
y celebraciones de piel.
¿Cuántos recuerdos anclados
en silenciosa entradas?
El día de tu muerte quedará
todo tu muro disponible.
Alguien marcará 'me gusta'.
¿Quién subirá
una foto contigo?
¿Quién tu canción
de ebriedades fijarán
mensajes cursis?
Ah, ¡escribanos de insomnios!
¡Ah, ¡ulises sedentarios!
¿Cuántos espectros desguasados
arrastra el libro de caras?"
Muy bien. Este texto, este es
un conjunto de cuatro textos.
Estos cuatro textos
tienen que ver con --
El diario -- un supuesto diario
secreto de Marilyn Monroe.
Aquí voy a hacer un comercial.
Mi novela, "Marilyn en el
caribe" partió de estos textos,
se basa en el hecho de que un
jardinero de Los Ángeles,
quiere el jardinero del
barrio de Marilyn Monroe,
cuando ella muere, por alguna
razón le llega a sus manos el
diario secreto, y entonces,
se cree perseguido por el FBI,
por la mafia, por todo el
mundo y huye para México.
En México se asila en Cuba y
cambia el diario por el asilo al
servir -- a la cancillería
Cubana.
Entonces, él vive ahí.
El diario tiene estos textos.
Estos son los textos que están
dichos en la voz de Marilyn.
Tengo la voz un poco gruesa
como para ser la voz de Marilyn,
pero trataré de leerlo
como si fuera ella.
Son cuatro textos de
cuatro momentos de su vida.
El primero, el primer texto
tiene que ver con la última
película de Marilyn,
"The misfits" --
Y dice así.
"El sexo es parte
de la naturaleza,
y yo me llevo de
maravilla con ella.
Arthur Miller decía que el
poder es un afrodisíaco para
las mujeres y que las rubias
somos especialmente sensibles a
su aroma.
Yo duermo vestida con solo
una gota de Chanel número 5.
Para mi gusto, el poder apesta.
El sexo es siempre una
complicación para los hombres
de letras.
Escriben demasiado sobre él.
Se mortifican con el
recuerdo de vida que les toca.
Arthur, amor inútil, me hizo la
Rosalynn de la película final.
Clark Gable me regaló la
sabiduría de su vejez,
y siendo Rosalynn
fui su última yegua.
¿Por dónde andas,
Joe Di Maggio?
Los peloteros mascan tabaco de
Virginia y son buenos amantes".
Happy birthday, mister
president.
"Jack nunca pensaba demasiado
cuando un día su cabeza entre
mis piernas largas que apuntaban
orgiásticas a la luna.
El hombre más poderoso del
mundo se arrodilla ante mí
y tiemblo.
Mister president es la prueba
de que los maridos son buenos
amantes cuando están
traicionando a su mujer.
Happy bithday, católico y
rijoso como buen irlandés.
Con sus hombres de gafas oscuras
apostados en los recibidores de
nuestros hoteles alcahuetes,
Hoover nos cronometra
cada orgasmo.
Jack lo sabe, y es
temeroso de ese dios.
Sus esbirros no servirán para
un carajo el día que alguien
me disparé.
Los políticos son
maña y silencio,
y el poder el único
orgasmo por el que matarían.
Cuando los hombres se quedan
callados después del sexo,
es porque se acerca el fin.
Ahora lo sé.
El hombre más poderoso del
mundo finalmente es solo un
hombre, y la verdad del amor no
se lleva bien con la crueldad
del Estado.
¿Es tu casa mi hogar
todavía, Joe Di Maggio?
Two strikes, three balls,
¿te vas o te quedas?"
El hermano menor.
"Robert ha sido un consuelo.
Los hermanos menores siempre
son un triste consolador.
Es dulce pero se caga de miedo.
Le teme a Hoover, a Ethel,
su mujer, a la mafia,
le teme a su cuerpo
y nunca se entrega,
y su Rolex es una bomba
del tiempo entre los dos.
Habla demasiado y yo me
ahogo en sus secretos.
Por estas minucias resulta que
degüellan a las concubinas.
Robert quiere que
mantenga cerrada la boca.
Los hermanos menores siempre
se encoñan y son exigentes.
Es hipócrita y violento
pero sonríe bien.
Quiere apropiarse de los
recuerdos de mi niña violada.
Sembró sus secretos en mi
pretende cosechar mi silencio.
¿Correrías a home por mí,
señor Di Maggio,
56 veces seguidas?
¿Celebrarías mi funeral, Joe?
¿Llevarías flores a
mi tumba cada semana?"
Agosto 4, 1962.
"Soy una muñeca moribunda,
cebada de cocaína.
Muñeca de nembutal bajo las
oscuras luces de Hollywood.
Pero voy a ventilar
este maldito asunto.
Ni Frank Sinatra ni sus
mafiosos podrán detenerme.
Todo apesta y vomitaré sobre
el mantel del banquete de
los cerdos.
Que venga la prensa y que
caiga sobre todos ellos.
Las moscas son felices cuando
se posan sobre la mierda.
Estoy tiritando en pleno
verano y ya los veo.
Temo a la solitaria noche de
Los Ángeles y ya los veo.
Oh Joe, no permitas que
ellos se me acerquen.
¿Por qué diablos no
contestas el teléfono, Joe?
¿Por qué?"
Esta es otra sección del libro,
es una sección que trabaja
sobre noticias del periódico.
Cosas que han aparecido,
que aparecen en la prensa
y que responden a ese --
A eso que pasa en el mundo.
El poema que voy a leer se llama
"mis hermanos en
la madre patria".
Ustedes saben, en el año 2000,
el Ecuador tuvo una crisis
bancaria muy fuerte que lo
llevó a perder su
moneda nacional.
Nosotros tenemos como
moneda el dólar hoy día.
También hay el dólar
canadiense,
el dólar norteamericano
y el dólar ecuatoriano.
¿Perdón?
Yo no sé.
Es el mismo dólar.
O sea, no tenemos
moneda nacional nosotros,
funcionamos con el
dólar como moneda.
Pero eso motivó una migración
muy fuerte hacia España,
y más o menos se calcula que
hay unos 800.000 ecuatorianos en
España productos de
ese proceso migratorio.
Esos ecuatorianos en seguida
forman una comunidad y esa es la
comunidad de la que
hablo en este texto.
Mis hermanos en la madre patria.
"En los domingos veraniegos
del parque del retiro,
más amontonados que
botellines de Cruzcampo,
con canastas repletas de
tamales y cochinillos,
mote y salchichón, un hablar
que mezcla la cerrazón andina y
el desparpajo costeño,
con el acento castellano de los
sudacas que creen mimetizarse,
cantan mis hermanos que no
conozco las tonadas tristes con
las que alegramos nuestra
vida en la mitad del mundo.
Deslucen la modernidad de los
españoles de sentimientos
discretos, elegantes,
poco afectos al melodrama,
pese a las pelis de Almodóvar.
A los niños pijos de La
Castellana les disguste ese
impertinencia migrante que no
olvida el viento melancólico de
los páramos de las serranías,
que recuerda con su
caminar desinhibido,
el bochinche de un puerto".
'Ah, estos pobres sudacas.
Que se vayan a los campos de
Murcia que manos se necesitan
para esta vendimia.
Que se queden en Madrid de
arreglando las habitaciones de
los hoteles que llegan
los turistas alemanes.
¡Pero joder!
Que no salgan a las calles con
esas cabezas de cerdas y esas
barrigas que sobresalen por
la pretina de los jeans MNG'.
Mis hermanos ecuatorianos,
sudacas de pequeña
estatura y talla L,
mujeres bellas y dulces como
un durazno de Ambato que cuidan
a ancianos.
Varones dedicados a colocar
mil bloques de cemento para el
edificio del día.
Trabajan en todo lo que esos
niños pijos jamás harían,
aunque les cayera
el ajuste del PP,
la severidad de la Merkel y
la abolición de la siesta.
Viven amontonados,
ahorrando euros,
con la sonrisa digna
del honrado.
Hablan con faltas de ortografía
al pronunciar las ces y
las zetas.
Putean con arrogancia cuando
exigen sus derechos en
los consulados.
Tocan guitarra y cantan en los
condominios para escándalo de
sus vecinos.
Se visten de Zara y gustan del
arte del cachondeo y la caña
del mediodía.
Los domingos se multiplican
en el retiro y mis hermanos
persisten, celebrando la vida,
mezclando a Sharon
con Julio Jaramillo,
llevando en procesiones a
la Virgen Churona, llorando,
maldiciendo y extrañando al
paísito imaginario irreal.
Ah, y una foto de Barcelona
Sporting Club de Guayaquil en su
cuartito de lavapiés.
A veces, algunos de ellos,
contempla desde el mínimo
balcón de su piso el atractivo
vacío que besa el
asfalto húmedo de otoño,
por si llegaron los alguaciles
con el apremio de la orden
de desahucio."
Este poema tiene una
historia muy dura.
Rosa Elvira Cely fue una
mujer qué fue víctima de un
feminicidio en Bogotá.
Un hombre que había sido su
pareja con engaños la llevó al
Parque Nacional, la golpeó, la
torturó y la empaló y murió.
Lo importante de la historia
es que eso motivó que un
movimiento de ciudadanos
planteara una reforma al Código
Penal Colombiano e instituyera
la figura de feminicidio,
el delito de feminicidio,
que no existía en Colombia.
Entonces, a partir de eso se
hizo una ley que es la ley Rosa
Elvira Cely, que tipificó
el delito de feminicidio por
primera vez en Colombia.
Me tocó participar de cerca en
este proceso y estuve cerca de
la hermana y de la
familia de ella entonces,
este poema tiene mucho
significado y sentido para mí.
"No sólo es el suplicio
inenarrable de tu agonía,
entre los árboles
solitarios del Parque Nacional.
Es la sevicia de un hombre,
la complicidad de
todos los hombres,
la vasta crueldad de la
condición masculina.
Tu sexo atravesado por
la furia del falócrata,
tu vientre hollado por
la violencia del amo,
tu cuerpo que ya no es
tuyo sino del tormento.
Rosa Elvira Cely, 35 años,
una niña de 12 martirizada,
la dignidad de la vida con
la atrocidad de tu muerte".
Este texto tiene que ver con
lo acaecido con 43 maestros
en Ayotzinapa.
"43 corazones extraviados en
la muda herida de la tierra.
43 esqueletos calcinados
bajo el sombrero emplumado de
la catrina.
43 silencios como calabacitas
inútiles en el lecho de
un río.
43 soñadores del abecedario
y los números para niños de
pupitres vacíos.
43 desaparecidos que son
estadística junto a miles que
tampoco están y
también amaron.
43 calvarios para que la poesía
abandone el pueril malestar
del poeta".
Esta es una parte que tiene
que ver con la experiencia
en Colombia.
Yo he seleccionado unos poemas
relacionados con la literatura.
Este primero no creo que tenga
que decirles de qué se trata.
Primer viaje a Macondo.
"Navidad de 1974.
A mi tía Maruja le regalaron
'100 Años de Soledad' y ella
pensó que sería una historia
igual que las de la Biblia,
algo menos sangrienta pero más
evocativa del paraíso perdido.
Nadie supo con qué mañas
los gitanos de Melquiades
atropellaron la casa de mi tía,
ni como la descomunal boa del
joven José Arcadio Buendía
glorificó el pecado de la carne
por artes de pilar ternera.
Mi tía dejó de leer la novela
y su crítica fue un rosario y
sus letanías.
García Márquez cayó en
el tacho de basura condenado
por obsceno.
Yo, que ya sabía el significado
de la palabra 'obsceno',
aproveché la hora de los
rezos para rescatar la novela
del basurero.
Fue una primera lectura
clandestina, pantagruélica,
afiebrada y decidí extraviarme
bajo la lluvia de flores
amarillas y los ceibales
de Manabí,
en las bananeras sembradas de
olvido y el camión de mi padre
que extravió el camino
de regreso a casa,
en las sábanas de la
asunción de Remedios la bella,
como en la piel morena y
etérea de Martita mi vecina.
En las guerras perdidas del
coronel Aureliano Buendía y la
pira en la que terminó
nuestro general de las derrotas.
En las penas de amor de Mauricio
Babilonia y las propias,
en el espejo hablado de los
pergaminos y los rumores que
persiguen los pasos de Marian
Gul en busca de sus tripas.
En esa geografía de curas que
levitan sin senderos de regreso
a Dios.
En los carnavales del
'75, luego de las fiebres,
me convertí en ciudadano de
Macondo y renació mi segunda
oportunidad de ser
sobre esta tierra."
El año pasado se celebraron
150 años de la novela
"María" de Jorge Isaacs.
Es interesante, "María" se
publicó en 1867 y es, digamos,
la novela paradigmática,
tal vez la mejor novela del
romanticismo latinoamericana,
si es que hay -- si
se puede decir eso,
pero indudablemente la novela
más importante de la narrativa
romántica del siglo XIX,
"María" de Jorge Isaacs.
En 1967, 100 años después, se
publicó "100 Años de Soledad",
también de otro Colombiano,
que es la novela emblemática de
la literatura hispanoamericana
del siglo XX.
Entonces, siempre van a estar
unidos en sus conmemoraciones.
El año pasado se conmemoraron
50 años de la aparición de
"100 Años de Soledad" y 150
años de la aparición de
"María" de Jorge Isaacs.
En Cali -- cerca de Cali,
en el municipio Santa Elena,
está la casa que era
de la familia Isaacs.
Lo interesante de esa casa es
que hoy día es una casa museo
-- lo interesante es que
cuando uno va a visitarla,
los guías mezclan
biografía con ficción.
Entonces, dicen, "este
es el cuarto de Efraín,
aquí dormía Efraín, ¿no?
Y este es el cuarto de María y
aquí se bañaba Efraín y aquí
se bañaba María".
Esa casa ya no pertenecía a
los Isaacs cuando Jorge Isaacs
escribió la novela en
1867, pero en todo caso,
pasear por la casa de María
y Efraín es una experiencia
muy linda.
Éste es un texto que rinde
homenaje a esa experiencia.
Como ustedes ven, aquí está el
frente de la casa, los jardines,
el cuarto de María,
el cuarto de Efraín.
"La casa está invadida por el
susurro de los besos ausentes,
y el olor de las rosas de
los jardines cultivados en
la espera.
Es perfume memorioso de los
ritos de la flor de cada día
que Efraín contemplo en su
mesa, iluminada de mañana,
como aquella niña de Jamaica,
belleza de las mujeres de su
raza y la sangre enferma que
heredará de su madre,
descendiente de las
hijas de Jerusalén.
Esa muchacha judía, de nombre
Esther, de trenzas libres,
mirada seductora, virgen
de la silla de Rafael,
supo del lenguaje de las flores
y la sensualidad del agua.
Baño poblado de pétalos que
envuelven la piel del ansia
escondida, posó sus labios
en los labios de su amado,
sin tocarlos".
"Caricia frutal en la ausencia
y pálpito de la muerte,
graznido del ave de espantos.
Recorrer la casa es ser testigo
de un amor pueril pero intenso
en las palabras, en las miradas,
en los gestos, en los silencios.
Es revivir en el patio la
música que confunde la fiesta y
los sufrimientos
antiguos que provienen del
África violentada.
El visitante imagina ecos de
los cañaverales y el trapiche,
de las lecturas de
Chateaubriand,
de los ladridos de mayo.
Bisbiseos de los amantes que
lloran y uno siente que el
paraíso no lleva
su nombre en vano".
Rosario Tijeras es una es un
personaje de una novela de Jorge
Franco, famosa también
porque hubo una telenovela --
hay una telenovela que se llama
"Rosario Tijeras"
y era famosa --
bueno, este personaje de
Rosario Tijeras, porque,
como dice el bolero,
"con un beso la vida,
con un beso la muerte", bueno,
ella besaba y le
disparaba a los que besaban,
entonces, era casi textual.
Este texto se llama "Yo no
besé a Rosario Tijeras".
"Tengo miedo de besar
a Rosario Tijeras,
pero más son las ganas y no me
importa está poca vida entre la
vendedora de rosas y Satanás.
Quiero ese beso invocando a la
virgen de los que limpian las
balas con agua bendita y bailar
contigo antes de aquel disparo
que suena tu muerte.
Pero no llegaré a
tiempo, niña de nadie,
y escaparé a tu furia contra
este mundo de poca mierda,
en ese desbarrancadero
que llaman metrallo".
Este texto es un texto muy
personal, y tiene que ver con --
Con mi padre.
El texto se llama "Padre,
¿extraviaste nuestros
nombres acaso?
Es un texto que tiene
seis estancias.
Y habla del padre que
abandona el hogar.
"Padre, no sé dónde estás.
Te fuiste antes de que yo
naciera y me quedé sin tu
nombre y sin tu abrazo.
Fui un perro extraviado
en una playa sin fin.
Después te vi en tardes
evaporadas pero no me acuerdo de
tus ojos ni de tus manos
ni del sonido de tu risa.
Eres el silencio
permanente de mi extravío.
Solo recuerdo tu rostro
dormido en el ataúd,
rodeado de tus otros
hijos, de tu otra casa.
Estabas hermoso y frío como
esas estatuas esculpidas
en mármol.
Me acompaña la desesperación
de esa mosca que besaba tus
párpados, ofuscada y sin salida
ya también dentro del féretro.
Fui esa mosca extraviada en tu
muerte, y sin embargo, padre,
somos el pálpito de la
vida y yo tu progenie.
Padre, yo no pude matarte sino
a través de mi propia muerte.
Todo lo que tuve de ti en
mi niñez fue esa volqueta
fabricada en hierro que
arrastré por las calles
polvorientas del vecindario
junto a mi tristeza infantil.
Yo era un nómada sin pasado,
paseante de barrio sin historia.
Un día regalé la volqueta a
un niño con el rostro aún más
desolado que el mío.
Niño de pobreza
de postal amarga.
Al desprenderme de
aquel juguete,
maté mi infancia y me
quedé nuevamente sin ti.
Me convertí, padre, en un
adolescente de huesos de ceniza.
Sobre mi huérfana delgadez,
llevé nuestros cadáveres
a cuestas.
Padre, he vivido en orfandad
sin que te hubieras enterado de
tu muerte.
Ausencia a la que nos sometiste
durmiendo en la cama matrimonial
de tu otro hogar.
¿Alguna vez sentiste
remordimiento por el rito de
hombre que repetiste, igual
que aquellos otros hombres que
también carecían de futuro?
Mi orfandad tiene el rostro de
un niño solitario que juega en
tardes calurosas, con
amigos que sólo él ve,
amables fantasmas vespertinos.
Mi condición de adolescente sin
padre es tan dura como la roca
del acantilado, que recibe
el golpe furioso del mar e
imperceptible se va desgastando.
Tu abandono, padre, me acarició
desde siempre como la lluvia que
besa la playa, que deja huellas
de gotas sobre la arena que el
mar borra enseguida.
Mis recuerdos de ti son como los
peces muertos que los pescadores
dejan en el vientre de las
canoas para que los devoren
las gaviotas.
Padre, devuélveme esa
condición de hijo tuyo que
nunca tuve.
"Padre, me debes la mirada
dolorida de mi madre.
Sus ojos de un azul grisáceo
que nos miraban con la
somnolencia de Penélope.
Me debes también la madurez
apresurada de mi hermano,
sus largos días de trabajo para
que nuestra mesa siempre oliera
pan fresco.
Me debes los suspiros
de mi hermana,
que siempre te buscó como si
ella fuera la que se hubiera
marchado de casa.
Me debes la vergüenza pueril
de andar por la vida sin padre".
Padre, no tengo una
sola fotografía tuya.
Tu rostro se ha desvanecido
en mi memoria,
desteñido daguerrotipo
del fracaso.
Eres una sonrisa
difusa como neblina,
una mirada opaca como
cristal de mala calidad,
una palabra muda
como cementerio.
Eres tinta que se escurre
de una acuarela humedecida
en lágrimas.
¿Cómo acariciabas a un
niño cuando yo era niño?
¿Dónde andabas cuando mi
adolescente buscaba a quién
parecerse en espejos
de fantasmas?
Padre, eres polvo tras una
lápida que no conozco.
Eres desilusión del
buscador de tesoros,
en la tumba en la que
habré de encontrarte".
Y seis. "Padre, nunca tu voz me
leyó un cuento para proteger
mi sueño.
Descubrí por mí mismo un
pequeño príncipe venido a la
tierra desde un asteroide
lejano.
A una niña que tras perseguir a
un conejo blanco apurado llega a
un mundo de maravillas.
A un burrillo que descansa entre
las rosas cercanas del cielo de
Muger, a una viuda del tamarindo
que espantaba el espanto del
día alrededor de
una fogata nocturna.
Las palabras que jamás obtuve
de ti me la dijeron los libros
en los que fundí mis
ojos cargados de abandono.
Ahora, padre, yo mismo escribo
los cuentos para mi desvelo,
y no es en vano.
Escribo con la palabra que
sostienen mi agonía de ser el
verbo que me ha liberado
para siempre de tu ausencia".
Finalmente, quiero cerrar con
este autorretrato un poco más
-- un poco más actual.
Es un retrato del año 2015.
"El acertijo de mundo que soy es
poema habitado por nombres que
evocó en vano.
Transparencia de rosa desnuda en
jardín que pregunta si soy Juan
Ramón Jiménez, y como César
Vallejo padezco en jueves duros
el hambre de mis
huesos húmeros.
Juana Inés de la Cruz,
si el claustro de mi sexo
en barroco hipérbaton es
la necedad".
Tinta verde, caldillo de congrio
y América siendo Pablo Neruda
fueron mi sur.
Rubén Darío, Traje de cisne
y Japonerías tras púrpuro
cartinaje de un Versalles
otoñal.
Porfirio Barba Jacob, sinestesia
que agita de voluptuosidad de
una fruta en mi mano.
Testarudo sobre un mulo al
filo del abismo como Lezama,
rapsoda de Trocadero,
y soy Jorge Enrique Adoum cuando
una mujer desnuda marxista en mi
ecuador amargo.
Alejandra Pizarnik,
si metáforas de seconal me
ofrecen un sueño que eterno
se deslíe.
Soy espectro del que fui y
esbozo del que anhela ser en
esta innominada poesía mía".
[ Aplausos ]
Bueno, muchísimas gracias
a todas las personas que han
resistido heroicamente
esta lectura de poesía.
Si hay -- [inaudible]
[ Aplausos ]